I'm Greg Gutfeld along with Katie
Pavlich Jessica tarlock Jesse Watters
and Sandra Smith the five
[Music]
well Mr taibi was testifying the
Internal Revenue Service paid a visit to
his home left a note on his door saying
we'll be back in touch with you next
week we still do not have the answers
from the IRS about that unlikely
coincidence the Secretary of Treasury
admitted only happens so far as she
knows when someone is under
investigation for fraud
Republicans are demanding answers from
Joe Biden on the weaponization of
government there's a damning new
controversy after the IRS showed up at
the home of a Twitter files journalist
mataibi the same day he was testifying
on big Tech censorship seems like a
pretty big deal that Biden should want
to address but his administration has no
explanation
does that bother you it's certainly
something that I would want to look into
I'm not aware that IRS agents do that
except as you said in cases where
there's an investigation that's
wondering if you could respond to this
taibi visit by the IRS I'm afraid I'm
gonna have to refer you to the IRS
that's stonewalling not sitting well
with Jim Jordan the chairman telling
Biden it's time to start talking
just give us the answer and if it's if
it is chance then just tell us but tell
us what it is I don't know how it takes
so long to figure this out we may look
to subpoena the documents any
Communications relative to this
situation we may want to talk with folks
who's that lady on the left a suspicious
IRS house visit is just one of the
problems Republicans also trying to get
to the bottom of how government and big
Tech teamed up to censor information a
former Attorney General turned Senator
testified about why he sued the Biden
Administration by Administration has led
the largest speech speech censorship
operation in recent American history and
no matter what your political
affiliation is government censorship
should concern everyone the hunter Biden
laptop Story the covid-19 lab League
story Theory and the efficacy of masks
Discovery obtained by Missouri and
Louisiana demonstrated the Biden
administration's coordination with
social media companies and collusion
with non-profits to censor speech was
far more pervasive and destructive than
ever known all right Katie so do you
sense a pattern taking shape
um with government targeting yes which
is why they're having these hearings but
specifically with the IRS you remember
that Joe Biden was vice president when
the IRS was going after uh conservatives
for speaking out against Obamacare
during the Obama Administration and
served under a president who went after
more journalists and sources than any
other in history of the country and that
was Barack Obama he put in more more
sources in jail than anyone else so for
all the talk about how president Trump
you know was hard on the Press you'd
think that Joe Biden would come out and
defend reporters in this instance
Democrats who say that they're for the
first amendment that it's an important
part of the country would be asking
questions of the IRS as well for this
visit and you know what maybe it is a
coincidence
maybe I don't believe that the IRS
hasn't said it's just a coincidence but
at a time of deep distress with the
government in a time when they're under
the microscope by this committee you
would think that they would go out of
their way not to do things like this
especially when it's not routine yeah
Sandra what do you make of the whole
idea of it being a coincidence how can
how can it be a coin this is just too
rare and shouldn't the IRS be talking
about this it feels so blatant too
because to Jim Jordan's point in that
interview thank you by the way that was
me yes um and that was earlier uh and he
made some news in there he said I said
what if the IRS does not respond by your
given deadline so they'll move on to a
subpoena but good luck I don't know
where you get with that we might never
get answers here but just feels so wrong
like why did this have to happen you
know I talked to Liz McDonald yesterday
from the Fox Business Network she's
covered the IRS for decades she said
this is not this is there's no reason
why some somebody couldn't have called
him up before this happened and then to
not have them comment at all on this to
Jim Jordan's point about is this a
coincidence is there anybody who doesn't
think that this actually that he was
targeted Matt Tybee by the way not
necessarily a conservative journalist or
I now I guess now they're questioning
whether or not he's a journalist to
begin with but we should all be
concerned if a government agency is
acting in this way and people should be
demanding that we get to the bottom of
this we should be demanding that we get
answers and for the IRS did not comment
on it that sends a message in and of
itself
they could say no actually just you know
this is just coincidence this just
happened by chance tell us if that's the
case
Jessica you must be disgusted by your
party
I've re-registered on the way to work
you can do it on your phone now
um so that's how you do it
what bothers me well a I'm bothered that
the IRS showed up there and has it and
hasn't explained it to your point if it
was a coincidence say it even if it
wasn't probably recommend lying about
that because it looks really bad and
it's even made the Liberals mad about it
but the thing that bothers me the most
about it is people showing up for
hearings not prepared for the questions
that you know that you're going to get
we talked about this yesterday with
secretary mayorkis getting questions
about the bracelets for instance which
Jesse brought up as an example
Janet Yellen could have known if you
look at the news cycle if you look at
what's going on with Jim Jordan is
commenting on when he does his cable
news hits Etc you have a good idea of
what the stories are that are really
fueling these people so why wouldn't you
in the interest of being able to get to
your points because when you have to
address other people's points what
happens is I know this well since my
time gets taken up but Jesse's
interruptions often you don't get to say
what you wanted to say how dare you
Jessica
um so know what they're going to ask you
and then come with a good response to it
she could have reached out to someone I
would imagine and say what's going on
with this Matt taibi thing I'm going to
be asked about it and then she could
have said I have a call into blah blah
blah like Kirby said you're gonna have
to talk to the IRS I have a statement
other things that I want to say about
your intro I think it's
no I I think it's excellent
thank you it's intro it's just fun no it
was really excellent try to give him a
compliment yeah what are you going I
successfully did it Jim Jordan saying
I'm gonna move on to a subpoena is
laughable he's like 363 days now he
hasn't complied with the subpoena that
he got from the January 6th committee
and all of this testimony about how the
Biden Administration is colluding with
the social media companies we have all
of the evidence now of what the Trump
Administration was doing from things
like help us deal with the Panic buying
that happened at the beginning of the
pandemic when everyone wanted to get all
the masks all the Clorox Etc to I'm
really mad that Chrissy Teigen called me
uh you know what so no one who doesn't
love Jim Jordan or subscribed to that
kind of world view is buying what's
coming out of this committee speaking of
Jim Jordan Jesse I want to play some
more sound and on tape of how uh he it's
about how the Dems tried again to censor
what's happening let's listen to this in
today's hearing the Democrat members of
the committee tried to strike from the
white record Senator Schmidt's testimony
and attorney general Landry's testimony
so first they say there's no there's no
censorship really happening here and
then they try to censor the testimony
and remove it from the record because we
followed custom and they didn't answer
questions uh uh as is always the
customer when you have a senator and a
former member come in front of Congress
and that I think just describes what the
Democrats are really up to Jesse we're
living in a strange era we're seeing
another flip in the world of speech
where it's the right who are The
Defenders of free speech whether it's on
campuses like Stanford or in social
media Industries and now in government
it's and now it's the left that are
trying to silence people what's
happening here what's going on
underneath that fake head of hair of
yours
well I knew this was going to happen
when we elected a president from
Delaware this is what you get you get a
brute and Katie's right that they've
been going after journalists for as long
as he's ever been in power they cracked
into Tucker phone when he was trying to
book Putin they cracked into rosen's
phone they kicked down James O'Keefe's
door in the middle of the night and
hauled him off in his underwear those
perverts and then Biden comes out and
does an interview on the Super Bowl not
with Brett Berry does it with Drew
Barrymore yes so this guy is just a
corrupt deep State stooge who goes from
abusing power to hiding to lying rinse
lather repeat and the whole country is
stuck on their little chinese-made
iPhones he's waiting for baseball season
to start I'm a little annoyed with these
hearings they're wasting my time Yellen
comes out and she has no clue what's
going on mayorcas doesn't know what a
cartel wristband looks like Austin at
defense has never heard of the fact that
they're booking drag shows at Air Force
bases and all you have to do if you're a
flack you say I'm just gonna have to
refer to this person I'm just gonna have
to refer you this person you don't have
to know anything you don't have to do
anything so if I was in Congress I would
say Janet what'd you do to prepare for
the hearing today when's the last time
you spoke to the IRS commissioner do you
even care what's going on at the IRS
what do you do all day she can't answer
that question instead they're gonna like
throw a subpoena around okay well then
what another subpoena and then what
another subpoena and then we're all dead
yes that's how it works that's how it
works exactly they subpoena you to death
and then you're dead and then you're
dead yeah or you retire like Lois Lerner
consequences well we still have nothing
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else